this was a popup exhibit for first year
physics students and it's all about
introducing them to rare books that are
related to their first year physics
classes and that means that these are
the oldest and rarest books at the Bina
key
all to be able to share that with my
students and to see how excited they all
were undergraduate students graduate
students it was just such a treat I
think that these books are so important
even in 2023 for a few reasons number
one a lot of the things that they wrote
down are still true today and that's the
amazing thing about science currently
inventing calculus oh that's super cool
the second thing is that some of these
books go into great detail about how
difficult these calculations were and
those kind of feelings are the things
that we also feel as researchers and
scientists and so giving students that
connection it's just such an amazing
link to the past and make these books
really relevant not only from the
historical point of view but from a
cultural scientific point of view these
are their academic ancestors for me
that's the most important thing is
saying that these really famous
scientists that are elevated were
clearly brilliant people but they're
still just people and the books
themselves have such interesting
character there's other people that
wrote in the margins and really just the
sense of holding a piece of history in
your hand it was really
[Music]
incredible